The Never Kevin caucus.
That is what
a tiny group of House
Republicans are calling themselves
vowing
at least at all odds to deny
Kevin McCarthy the speakership.
So this week,
McCarthy's more moderate
allies decided to label themselv
the only Kevin Caucus,
and they even made these handy l
Okay, buttons,
which can be read
a couple of different ways
as only Kevin will be
the next speaker of the House
or that their guy,
the Republican leader
who led them to the majority in
is just. Well. Okay.
So the question
now remains, can those moderates
drag their leader across the fin
16 days from now
and what cost are
they willing to pay in order to
We are back with our panel.
Okay, Kevin.
So is
this going
to be the time that the moderate
are able
to stand up to the hardliners an
Kevin McCarthy speaker?
Is that going to happen?
They don't have the numbers.
They don't have the numbers righ
By themselves to do that.
So some deal has to be struck he
And what can Kevin McCarthy
give the far right?
What can he give the Freedom Cau
What can you give essentially to
who caucus?
Not all of it
because some of the pro
who members are pro McCarthy as
What else can he give them?
He is already committed to discr
the January six investigation.
He's already committed to whitew
and trying to bury and rewrite
the history of the coup,
the one that
the one that he told his colleag
Donald Trump
should resign the presidency for
So the only thing he can give th
now is the very weapon
they will use later to destroy h
It's called a motion to vacate.
It's a little bit of House floor
procedural ism
that basically says
any member can call a vote
to depose the speaker at any tim
And it's real.
And if you want to know how real
just ask John Boehner.
It existed back
when John Boehner was speaker.
And it's the sword
they held over his head that eve
this has become kind of a
a major sticking point.
And as you said, it's
a little bit of a
kind of arcane language,
but it basically means
that they can get rid of the spe
at any time.
Just listen to kind of back
and forth
between one lawmaker
who is pushing for this
and another
who is saying,
at the end of the day,
this is all just going to cause
There's
no CEO in the country
that doesn't have accountability
There's nobody that goes to work
every day
that doesn't have accountability
The country can't wait
two years for an accountability.
You can't govern with a gun to y
You know,
and that's what they're asking f
You can scream the word accounta
all you want,
which is what they do,
and stand on their moral high ho
But in the end, it is
it is just a path to chaos.
Not stability.
I did wonder, though,
I mean, at the end of the day, W
even giving this to the Freedom
Caucus goers
secured the votes from McCarthy?
I just I just want to take a ste
let's let's say that McCarthy do
become speaker.
He can't even get his
caucus together right now
to elect him speaker
how are they going to legislate?
How are they going to do
anything next year?
If this vote is this problematic
you sign The Wall Street Journal
editorializing on this.
The reality is, is that they wer
planning on legislating.
No, no, not at all.
So I think that that's part
of the challenge.
No, but the question was like,
what investigations would they
put forward?
Focus on during the next two yea
Would it be on
Hunter Biden
or would it be on the DHS secret
Would it be on January six?
And that is for McCarthy
that's been the real incentive
he can dangle
in front of
dissenters and people
who are not sold on him yet.
But it doesn't seem to have sold
people at this point to he's alr
committed to those things. Right
Those things that you listed are
and he's already done it.
And he also was running out of b
He also has the support of forme
President Trump,
who told by on Friday, look,
I think this Kevin has worked ve
He is just
it's been exhausting
if you think he's been all over.
I think he deserves a shot.
Hopefully
he's going to be very strong
and going to be very good
and he's going to do what
everybody wants,
which is
maybe a great endorsement,
but maybe also a very tepid endo
Yeah.
And look,
if Donald Trump, in
calling some of these members,
can't convince them to drop thei
Kevin McCarthy,
then like what's going to do it?
You know,
and I think that shows the exten
to which
these five members in particular
who are this quote, never
Kevin Group are doing this
because they see the political i
in their districts
and they think it elevates them
on on the far right.
But to the question
of what can Kevin McCarthy do,
there's been this question
since the midterm elections,
since he secured this
narrower than expected majority
Is this going to
who is this going to empower?
And so far,
even though the moderates are ki
of stepping up a little bit here
We're still seeing that the Free
Caucus, the far right
folks in that caucus are the one
who are still holding the cards.
And that's because that's always
where the incentives are in a Ho
Republican caucus.
And we're seeing that continuing
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean,
I think
if anybody the winner here
is President Biden,
who now kind of by default
is going to get a Republican con
and doesn't have its act togethe